LEARNED.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE" ."
WE SAW THIS COMING ABOUT TWO
WEEKS AGO WHEN SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE BRETT KAVANAUGH --
REMEMBER WHEN HE FIRST APPEARED
BEFORE THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE?
RATHER THAN MOUNT ANY SERIOUS
ARGUMENT, DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
ACTIVIST ALLIES RESORTED TO
THEATRICS AND PAID, PREPLANNED
PROTESTS.
>> I WELCOME EVERYONE TO THIS
CONFIRMATION HEARING ON THE
NOMINATION --
>> MR. CHAIRMAN --
>> DRUDGE BRETT KAVANAUGH.
>> WE CANNOT POSSIBLY MOVE
FORWARD, MR. CHAIRMAN --
>> YOU ARE OUT OF ORDER.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN, --
>> AND MAKE SENSATIONS --
>> Laura: BARNUM AND BAILEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN PROUD.
UNABLE TO STOP KAVANAUGH, BASED
ON HIS JUDICIAL RECORD, WHICH IS
STELLAR, DEMOCRATS RESORTED TO
THIS LATE IN THE GAME SMEAR DROP
THAT THEY TRIED WITH MY OLD
BOSS, CLARENCE THOMAS, 17 YEARS
AGO.
YOU ALL KNOW BY NOW THAT
DIANNE FEINSTEIN SAT ON
DR. CHRISTINE FORD’S ALLEGATIONS
FOR SIX WEEKS, NEVER BRINGING IT
TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, UNTIL OF
COURSE IT WAS CONVENIENTLY
LEAKED.
THIS ALLEGED ASSAULT HAS NOT
BEEN CONFIRMED BY ANY OF THE
FOUR OTHER PEOPLE THAT SHE
CLAIMS WERE AT THE PARTY IN
QUESTION.
SHE WAS 15 AND KAVANAUGH WAS 17.
AND THEN YESTERDAY, A WEEK AFTER
THE FOUR DELEGATION CAME TO
LIGHT, ANOTHER DECADES-OLD
CLAIM SERVED SURFACE, THIS TIME
IN "THE NEW YORKER."
COLLEGE CLASSMATE OF KAVANAUGH,
DEBORAH RAMIREZ, CLAIMS THAT
WHILE A FRESHMAN IDEAL, HE
EXPOSED HIMSELF TO HER AT A
BOOZY DORM PARTY.
EVEN THOUGH SHE WAS DRINKING SO
MUCH, SO MUCH SO THAT SHE WAS
SLURRING HER WORDS AND FOGGY,
RAMIREZ SAYS HE SAW KAVANAUGH
PULLING UP HIS PANTS AFTER
SOMEONE EXPOSED THEMSELVES
TO HER.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN HIM.
WRITER RONAN FAIR RONAN FARROW A
WRITER RONAN FAIR RONAN FARROW D
WRITER RONAN FAIR RONAN FARROW J
WRITER RONAN FAIR RONAN FARROW N
NOTE THAT "THE NEW YORKER"
WRITER RONAN FAIR RONAN FARROW E
MAYER COUCHED THE ALLEGATION
SAYING "SENATE DEMOCRATS
INVESTIGATE NEW ALLEGATION OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT FROM BRETT
KAVANAUGH’S COLLEGE YEARS."
SO WHATEVER THE DEMOCRATS ARE
WITNESS, THE "THE NEW YORKER" AM
WITNESS, THE "THE NEW YORKER" AT
INVESTIGATING, IT LACKS A
WITNESS, THE "THE NEW YORKER" AS
THAT NO ONE WITNESSED THIS
ALLEGED INCIDENT.
IN FACT, RAMIREZ’S ROOMMATE, WHO
CLAIMS THAT THEY SHARED
EVERYTHING, HEARD NOTHING OF IT.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT THE DYNAMIC
JOURNALISTIC DUO OF BARROW AND
MAYER COULD FIND TO SUBSTANTIATE
THE CLAIMS REALLY DIDN’T.
>> THE CORROBORATING WITNESS
THAT YOU SAYS HAS ALL THE
DETAILS INCLUDING KAVANAUGH’S
NAME, WHERE DID THAT WITNESS
COME FROM AND WHERE DID THEY GET
THE INFORMATION ABOUT THIS FROM,
IF THAT PERSON DOESN’T KNOW
RAMIREZ?
>> HE REMEMBERS THAT -- HE WAS
IN THE SAME DORM, SAME LITTLE
BUILDING ON YALE’S OLD CAMPUS.
HE REMEMBERS IT CLEARLY.
I ASKED HIM, WE WERE GOING TO BE
VERY CAREFUL -- HE HEARD IT FROM
SOMEONE WHO WAS THERE.
>> Laura: HE HEARD IT FROM
SOMEONE AND A SMALL LITTLE DORM
ON THE OLD CAMPUS.
GREAT REPORTING.
ENTER STAGE LEFT THE OLD GRAY
LADY, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTS THAT THEY SPENT A WEEK
TRYING TO VERIFY THE RAMIREZ
STORY, INTERVIEWING SEVERAL
DOZEN PEOPLE, BUT -- DRUMROLL
PLEASE -- "COULD FIND NO ONE
WITH FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE.
THAT IS WHY THEY DIDN’T RUN WITH
IT.
MR. MRAZ CONTACTED FORMER YALE
CLASSMATES AND SHE ASKED IF THEY
WERE CALLED IF THE INCIDENT
NEVER HAPPENED AND TOLD SOME OF
THEM THAT SHE HERSELF COULD NOT
BE CERTAIN THAT MR. KAVANAUGH
WAS THE ONE WHO EXPOSED HIMSELF.
BUT WITHIN A SPAN OF SIX DAYS
AND AFTER CONSULTING WITH
CLASSMATES AND DEMOCRATS,
RAMIREZ MAGICALLY RECOVERED HER
HIDDEN MEMORIES.
HERE’S RONAN FARROW.
>> WHY DID YOU COME FORWARD?
>> SHE CAME FORWARD BECAUSE
SENATE DEMOCRATS BEGAN LOOKING
AT THIS CLAIM.
>> >> Laura: AHA!
NOW I KNOW WHY THE WHOLE CREW
WAS SO DESPERATELY WANTING TO
PUT OFF THOSE KAVANAUGH-FORD
HEARINGS, WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY
SCHEDULED FOR TODAY.
THEY NEEDED THEIR PILES IN THE
MEDIA TO HAVE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
JUMP ON WHAT THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING, THE DEMOCRATS,
AND FIND SOMEONE, ANYONE, WHO
KNEW KAVANAUGH AND COULD LEVEL A
SALACIOUS, OUTRAGEOUS CHARGE
AGAINST THEM.
WHO IS DEBORAH RAMIREZ?
WE DON’T KNOW ALL THAT MUCH
ABOUT HER.
SHE’S A REGISTERED DEMOCRAT WHO
"THE NEW YORKER" SAYS WORKS ON
BEHALF OF "SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
SOCIAL CHANGE."
OF COURSE, RIGHT ON CUE,
FEINSTEIN IS NOW DEMANDING THAT
THURSDAY’S HEARING BE POSTPONED
TO THE THIRD WEEK OF...
NEVER.
KAVANAUGH IS HIMSELF DEFIANT,
STANDING HIS GROUND AS HE TOLD
MARTHA MacCALLUM TONIGHT.
>> THE TRUTH IS, I’VE NEVER
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ANYONE.
IN HIGH SCHOOL OR OTHERWISE.
I AM NOT QUESTIONING AND HAVE
NOT QUESTIONED THAT PERHAPS
DR. FORD AT SOME POINT IN HER
LIFE WAS SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY
SOMEONE IN SOMEPLACE BUT WHAT I
KNOW IS THAT I HAVE NEVER
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ANYONE.
I WANT A FAIR PROCESS WHERE I
CAN DEFEND MY INTEGRITY, AND I
KNOW I AM TELLING THE TRUTH.
I KNOW MY LIFELONG RECORD.
I’M NOT GOING TO LET FALSE
ACCUSATIONS DRIVE ME OUT OF THIS
PROCESS.
I HAVE FAITH IN GOD AND I HAVE
FAITH IN THE FAIRNESS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
MAY BE FAIR BUT THE DEMOCRATS ON
THE COMMITTEE ARE CIRCLING.
>> DOESN’T KAVANAUGH HAVE THE
SAME PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AS
ANYONE ELSE IN AMERICA?
>> I PUT HIS DENIAL IN THE
CONTEXT OF EVERYTHING THAT I
KNOW ABOUT HIM IN TERMS OF HOW
HE APPROACHES HIS CASES.
HIS CREDIBILITY IS ALREADY VERY
QUESTIONABLE IN MY MIND AND IN
THE MINDS OF A LOT OF MY FELLOW
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBERS, THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: SHE GAVE IT ALL THE
WAY THERE.
IT’S NOT ABOUT WHETHER THESE
WOMEN HAVE BEEN WRONG.
MANY OF THEM PROBABLY HAVE.
IT’S NOT ABOUT RESPECTING THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE,
EITHER.
THIS IS ABOUT DENYING
DONALD TRUMP A FIFTH VOTE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS, I’M TELLING
YOU, THEY SHOULD TAKE A BREATH,
AND THEY SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE
NEW STANDARD THEY ARE SITTING
HERE FOR ALL NOMINEES GOING
FORWARD.
ARE WE REALLY SUGGESTING THAT
ALL ASPECTS OF FUTURE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEES, THEIR HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE BEHAVIOR, THAT SHOULD BE
SUBJECTED TO SCRUTINY AND
INVESTIGATION?
WELL, THAT SHOULD BE LOADS OF
FUN.
THE REPUBLICANS SHOULD HAVE HELD
THE VOTE LAST WEEK AS PLANNED.
KEN STARR SAID THAT A WEEK AGO
ON THIS PROGRAM.
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE INDULGED
THE CIRCUS.
HAD THEY DONE SO, THE RIGHT WAY,
JUSTICE AND KAVANAUGH WOULD
ALREADY BE SETTLING INTO HIS NEW
CHAMBERS AT THE SUPREME COURT.
AND A WARNING: IF HE IS NOT
CONFIRMED, REPUBLICAN VOTERS MAY